nice to see you yeah it's good to be
here good to be here I'm gonna bring up
cuz this became it was kind of a thing
at the time and it's all ancient history
because things happen so quickly now but
last time you're supposed to be on the
show you you cancelled at the last
second okay I put my I put my assistant
on the show Sona uh-huh and you know a
lot of people were talking about it
online Kumail didn't show up mm-hmm you
and I talked on the phone you were very
apologetic it was forces beyond your
control
mm-hmm it wasn't really your fault Riya
Riya daya you didn't want me to be here
yeah yeah but anyway you couldn't be
here it was just a thing and yeah and
the whole thing it was everywhere and
very last-minute I mean we had like the
show is like 20 minutes to air we were
about to start the audience was loading
in uh-huh we heard that you couldn't be
here I will say mm-hmm I was so tempted
to not show up today I was like that
would be a great bit yeah wouldn't that
be quick wouldn't show up no no that
would suck and you know what what I
would do I planned ahead I would be like
I'm not gonna show up and then I will
call you and apologize this is the most
sincere apology you've ever heard I'd be
like I'm so sorry please please book me
again I'll show up and the next time
you'd hook me and I wouldn't show up
again that would never just become your
thing
that would be it but I felt really bad
about missing it but like you said I was
shooting Silicon Valley and I couldn't
get out in time and I promise you that
show is dead to me I will never do
another episode that's really nice of
you because of me yeah I actually felt
really bad I don't know yet I know you
did tried to I'm such a huge fan of the
show and have been forever and I heard
the next day as soon as it woke up it
was like going viral that your Camaro
canceled and so this show was like sort
of this legendary show where you know it
was completely improvised and as the fan
I was really excited to watch and
improvise like my version of your show
and I started watching it and 90 seconds
in I started sweating and I got so I
I couldn't finish watching it too
someday I will we were talking about you
yeah yeah you were talking about me out
yeah not in favourable no no no no we
were we were all having fun with it no
it was good